ich möchte jetzt mal vorlesen was in
dieser sitzung passiert ist und zwar hat
es einen schlagabtausch zwischen
kanzlerin angela merkel und den berliner
regierenden bürgermeister müller gegeben
die kanzlerin merkel hat darauf bezug
genommen dass herr müller eben nicht so
einschneidende maßnahmen möchte wie sie
und hat gesagt herr müller sie gehen
doch auch mal durch berlin
herr müller geht in das gespräch rein
sagt darauf hin zur kanzlerin also im
tiergarten berliner tiergarten nur
wenige kilometer hier von unserem studio
entfernt also im tiergarten habe ich
noch keinen mit einer pizza oder einem
döner nachts gesehen
daraufhin die kanzlerin erneut sie gehen
doch abends auch die langen schlangen
vor dem lieblings töne am kudamm entlang
ich weiß nicht ob es dann dünner gibt
ich bin was die kanzlerin dem berliner
bürgermeister sagen möchte ist dass die
zustände in berlin darauf hindeuten dass
viele menschen ist noch nicht verstanden
haben was das kontaktverbot angeht und
der müller sagt darauf hin dass er
offenbar ausschließlich ab und zu mal im
tiergarten spazieren geht und da noch
kein mit einer pizza oder einem döner
nachts gesehen hat also tatsächlich
absurde donuts off szene könnte man
sagen wenn man für eine boulevardzeitung
arbeitet regiert also absurdeste dialoge
die dort geführt werden nach dreieinhalb
stunden muss man muss man leider so
sagen und die wichtigen themen weiterhin
alle abgeräumt alle abgeräumt die
ministerpräsidenten sind nicht bereit
irgendwas davon mitzumachen bislang was
die kanzlerin wollte weder die schnupfen
obst nicht dass ich jetzt doch aus dem
studio rennen muss also weder die
schnupfen quarantäne von fünf bis sieben
tagen noch die freizeit regel für die
kinder eins plus eins also dass man sich
nur noch mit einem freund treffen kann
keine masken pflicht in allen schulen
eben auch für grundschulkinder draußen
und drinnen was die kanzlerin wollte das
kontaktverbot was verschärft werden
sollte also nur noch mit mit einer
anderen person treffen auch abseits von
kindern auch das weg also bislang ein
total debakel für die kanzlerin wer dann
am ende recht behält werden wir sehen
was ich aus spd-kreisen höhe
er ist dass man er jetzt daran feilt wie
man nicht in ein politisches voll
kommunikations desaster läuft denn am
ende muss man den menschen irgendwas
erzählen und sagen was ist passiert ja
ich bin vor allem gespannt denn unser
regina bürgermeister wird ja später an
der seite von angela merkel da sitzen
müssen ob sie wollen oder nicht die
beiden also wir sehen gerade gleich
bilder aus berlin werden später bei
dieser pressekonferenz sitzen
wir sind sehr sehr gespannt was dabei
ich glaube man sollte die stühle
vielleicht ein bisschen weiter
auseinander rücken denn diejenigen die
da sitzen sind unter anderem michael
müller und die kanzlerin also man würde
gerne erfahren was wie dieser dünger
streit vielleicht dort bei der
pressekonferenz noch weiter ausgetragen
wird man weiß es nicht vielleicht
streitschlichter markus söder der
bayerische ministerpräsident musste
aufpassen dass die beiden nicht weiter
über döner diskutieren werden sie der
presse erzählen müssen was eigentlich
passiert mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren